can India become a superpower well of
course it can question is village and
how quickly without getting into all the
detail that in there are many reasons
why several experts believe that India
will become an affluent nation within
one generation and and all of that as an
Indian when I read them excited about
what I hate and deeply will like to have
them there are two or three challenges
that we have a face if it were to become
a superphone first is finding a body
which will drive inclusive growth
without which the shining in their story
and India become a superpower which we
talk about is likely to have a fairytale
ending because there will be far too
many people who will will not be part of
this wonderful economic growth story
what we talked about so to me India can
become a super car provided it embraces
the criticality of developing a model
which will drive inclusive growth and
get the billion plus people fully
integrated into the dog story